simplifica n al cuadrado por el re a la
quinta por n a la menos 7 y expresa tu
respuesta en forma exponencial con
exponentes positivos déjame reescribir
esta expresión acá abajo tenemos n al
cuadrado por r a la quinta por n elevado
a la menos 7 la manera más simple de
hacer esto antes de hacer la
multiplicación es agrupar los términos
que tienen la misma base en esta
expresión
tenemos dos términos que tienen la misma
base n n al cuadrado y n elevado a la
menos 7 entonces podemos escribir esta
expresión como en el cuadrado n al menos
r a la quinta y esto a que va a ser
igual bueno tenemos en el cuadrado por n
al menos 7 en este caso sumamos los
exponentes de tal manera que esto de
aquí va a ser igual a n elevado a la 2 -
72 menos 7 es menos 5 esto es n a la
menos 5 que multiplica a r a la quinta y
ya hemos simplificado al máximo la
expresión pero aún no hemos concluido
porque nos piden que expresemos nuestra
respuesta en forma exponencial y con
exponentes positivos positivos y aquí
tenemos un exponente negativo esta
respuesta no es la adecuada de acuerdo a
lo que nos están pidiendo ahora n a la
menos 5 n a la menos 5 lo podemos
escribir como 1 sobre n a la quinta
podemos usar eso en esta expresión así
es que esto de aquí este término lo
podemos expresar como 1 entre n a la
quinta que multiplica a r a la quinta lo
cual es igual a r la quinta sobre
n a la quinta sobre n a la quinta ya
está en su forma más simple quizás lo
que podemos hacer aquí dado que r jenn
están elevados a la quinta escribir esto
como r / n y eso elevado a la quinta
pero con esta respuesta ya hemos
cumplido con lo que nos están pidiendo
que es expresar con exponentes positivos
y lo hemos cumplido con pasar ese
exponente de al menos 5 como n a la
quinta en el denominador